Since Jesus is in his physical body now,
how can he indwell us? Who said that
he's physically indwelling us? Yousef.
So your mind is thinking Jesus fills us
in some physical way. Who told you that?
Who told you that Jesus is filling me in
a material physical substantial way?
Like here, who told you that like this
water filled the cup, Jesus is filling
me in a material, tangible physical way?
That's a gross misunderstanding of the
word fill. Jesus does not fill me
materially, spatially, physically like
water fills a cup. When we say Jesus
fills me, God fills me. The spirit fills
me. Father, son, and holy
spirit are not physical material
tangible entities. They don't have a
spatial
material body. And that spatial material
body then fills my internal organs. So
that if you cut me open, you're going to
see this material thing and that's God.
And the people are answering, "Isn't the
Holy Spirit? You guys don't know what
you're talking about either." See, this
is what happens when you're not
patient.
Okay? And I've already answered this in
the past. So wait, the Holy Spirit fills
me, but the Father and Son
don't. No, the Father fills everything.
The son fills everything. The Holy
Spirit fills everything. What do you
mean by fill? Fill. By fill, this is
biblical metaphor. And this is what it
means. Now, get ready to see what it
means. What does fill mean in reference
to God? A biblical metaphor meaning that
the entire
creation is preserved by God, overseen
by God and the
life, the gifts, the health, the
provisions that the entire creation
enjoy comes from God who's overseeing
creation, preserving
creation, bestowing health on creation,
life on creation.
provision on creation. It's simply a
biblical metaphor referring to the
provisions of God, to the spiritual
blessings of God, to the gifts of God,
to the life that comes from God, the
sustenance that comes from God. That's
all it means.
I'm going to prove that to you in a
minute. That's all it means. Everyone
get it now. What it means to be filled.
God is not a material being substance
made of substance like water. See, hey,
I filled my cup with water. God by
nature is not material. He's not
spatial. He's not physical. So, he
doesn't fill you with any stuff. Filling
is a metaphor. It is simply a term used
by Bible writers to to speak of God
overseeing all
creation being aware of every part of
creation that all creation is under his
control under his power under his
influence and all the life and the
blessings and the gifts and the health
and the provisions that all creation
enjoy come from
him. Is that clear?
Yeah. Now I'm going to show you from
scripture. That's the meaning. All
right. Are we ready now? Okay. Go to
Ephesians 4, read 7
to10. Ephesians 4 7
to10. And the father fills us, the sons
fills us, and the holy spirit fills
us. Read it for me, sister. Ephesians 4
7:10. Now, don't forget uh Ephesians is
before revelation.
Are you laughing at me?
It is before revelation. I'm just
laughing at Dino. What's wrong? Don't
get sensitive, Dino. She That means you
make her laugh. So, don't get so so
sensitive. Dino's the sensitive type.
When you start laughing at him, he's
always chilling by himself. He's saying
like, "See, there they go making fun of
me again, Sammy." Well, why don't you
just, you know, chill with Bruno? Oh,
you mean he's too hot to handle? Get it,
Bruno. Here. Okay, good. Ephesians
4:7-10. All right.
But unto every one of us is given grace
according to the measure of the gift of
Christ. You see grace, you're given
favor because of the gift of Christ. God
has gifted you because of his favor.
Right? Notice everyone, Yousef, the
connection with the favor of Christ and
the gift of Christ and the filling of
Christ. They're all interconnected
because notice grace, favor, gift of
Christ. Keep going.
Wherefore he saith, when he ascended up
on high, he led cap captivity captive
and gave gifts unto men. Okay. Now that
he gave what? Hold on. He gave what to
men? Gave gifts. Gifts to men. Now
notice the gifts that he gives to men
directly connected with Jesus filling
heaven and earth. Keep going.
Now that he ascended, what is it? But
that he also descended first into the
lower parts of the
earth. He that descended is the same
also that ascended up far above all
heavens, that he might fill all things.
Now the connection, do you see it? He
went to heaven. Now he fills all things.
Fills heaven and earth. How? You were
told by his gifts and his favor that he
lavishes on creation. And to further
prove that point, if you're paying
attention, to further prove that point,
reread 10 and 11. Now reread 10 and then
read 11 with it.
He that
descended is the same also that ascended
up far above all heavens, that he might
fill all things. And he gave some
apostles and some prophets and some
evangelists and some pastors and
teachers. You see the connection with
him filling heaven and earth with the
gifts that he gives to men and the
offices of the church that he
assigned. You see what it means now for
him to be filling. He doesn't fill in a
physical way, material way, substantial
way like the water fills this cup. He
fills in the metaphorical sense of
blessing creation with his provisions
with gifts with
sustenance with offices of the church in
order to help the members of his body to
grow spiritually until they attain full
maturity. In fact, now read 12-6. Finish
it.
Okay. um for the perfecting of the
saints, for the work. So why did he give
you apostles and prophets and teachers
and evangelists and pastors? Evangelists
and pastors and teachers. Apostles,
prophets, evangelists, pastors and
teachers. For what purpose? For the
perfecting, the maturing of the saints.
For the edifying of the body of Christ.
To edify, build up the body of Christ.
Keep going. till we all come in the
unity of the faith and of the knowledge
of the Son of God, unto a perfect man,
unto the measure of the stature of the
fullness of Christ,
that we h that we henceforth be no more
children, tossed to and fro, and carried
about with every wind of doctrine, by
the slight of men and cunning
craftiness, whereby they lie in weight
to deceive,
but speaking the truth in love may grow
up into him in all things which is the
head even Christ.
Don't forget 16. It's in your Bible.
From whom the whole body fitly joined
together and compacted by that which
every joint supplieth according to the
effectual working in the measure of
every part. Because it's the father who
fills you, the son who fills you, and
the spirit who fills you. All three fill
you because by filling it means the
father, the son and the spirit are the
ones who strengthen you, are the ones
who guide you, are the ones who sustain
you, are the ones who preserve you, are
the ones who correct you, are the ones
who teach you, are the ones who gives
you these gifts and all these offices so
that you can attain full spiritual
maturity and not be deceived by false
teachers leaving you confused and and
befuddled.
So what's the point of asking me he
filled you with the spirit? Because they
all three fill you
right everyone got it
now. Do you now understand what it means
to be filled? Yes. Jesus fills you with
the spirit. But what does that mean?
Jesus fills you with himself. What does
that mean? The father fills you with
himself. What does that mean? The father
fills you with himself. Fills you with
the son. Fills you with the spirit. What
does that mean?
right now. Here, go to Ephesians 3:19.
Okay. To know the love of Christ which
passes knowledge that you might be
filled with all the fullness of God.
What does it mean to be filled with the
fullness of
God? It doesn't mean God fills you in a
material spatial way. Right.
Yeah. It means he fills you in that
metaphorical sense that he gives you
everything you need and then some. He
gives you your provisions to live. He
also gives you all these offices of
ministry to help you achieve spiritual
maturity so you won't be deceived
anymore. He's he provides your
provisions. It refers to the gifts, the
favors, the provisions of the triune
God. That's all it
means. Everyone got it? if you're paying
attention and not letting Satan distract
you. Did everyone get it? Please let me
know you're getting it because it's for
your benefit. You got to learn your
theology. You got to learn how the Bible
functions. You got to learn biblical
terminology. You got to learn what these
terms mean and do not mean because God
by nature is spirit. Yes, Jesus became
flesh and as a man, he has a physical
body. But Jesus is not filling you as a
man. He's filling you by virtue of him
being God. And he fills you in union
with the father and the
spirit. If you define what filling
means,
right? Everyone got it?
Yeah.
You got it too, sister? Yeah. Got it.
Now, just to show you that filling is a
metaphor that's used to refer to God
overseeing all creation. That the entire
creation is in his control, in his
power. He's sustaining every part of
creation. So nothing's outside of his
control, his influence, his sight. Go to
Jeremiah 23:es 23 to 24.
23. 23 to 24. So I hope you got the
answer to that question, guys. We had
about 370. Let's pray that we go over
400 and keep it strong in Jesus name.
And Sarah Rainey, don't stay away too
long, sister. We love you, but not too
much. And we definitely don't love Sar
Gandhi as much. But go ahead.
What was it? Jeremiah 23. 23- 24.
Jeremiah 23. 23- 24.
Okay. Am I a god at hand, says the Lord,
and not a God a far off? Can any hide
himself in secret places that I shall
not see
him? Says the Lord. Do I do not I fill
heaven and earth? Says the Lord. Now, in
what context is God saying, I fill
heaven and earth? Read it again.
Jeremiah 23:23- 24. Notice in what
context is God saying, "I fill heaven
and earth."
Watch. Read it again. And am I a God at
hand, saith the Lord, and not a God a
far off? Can any hide himself in secret
places that I shall not see him? Sayaith
the Lord. Do not I fill earth, heaven
and earth, sayeth the Lord. Now you see
the context filling in the sense that I
see everything everywhere because
everything is in my control in my power
before my sight because there's not a
part of creation that I'm not
sustaining. Everyone got it
[Music]
now? So please guys, I know we are
physical temporal creatures bound to
time, space and place. So we interpret
things from that framework, from that
understanding, from that perspective cuz
we think fill and we think something
material spatial filling another
material object like water filling the
cup. But even in human language, don't
you say, "Man, I was filled with joy."
Now, does anyone actually think joy is a
spatial material object that if I cut
you open, it'll be right there somewhere
in your body expanding and growing
because you're getting filled with it?
Or we understand filled with joy is
metaphorical, right? I was filled with
joy. Well, you know what? Joy Robinson,
she be filling me with love. No, I'm
just kidding, right? You get it? Are you
laughing at me again?
Yeah, man. I'm I'm fil I'm filled with
rage right now, girlfriend. See, I'm
filled with rage.
Okay, I'm fil. Okay, block me. Block,
you know, don't block me. Oh, but you
get it. Who Who assumes that when you
say I'm filled with joy or I'm filled
with love or I'm filled with peace or
I'm filled with rage like I am right now
for you laughing at me? Who who thinks
that you mean man here is joy? It's 5'8
in, right? It weighs about 120 lbs. So
now I'm filling myself with it. Hold on.
Let me stuff myself down. Oh, there.
See, there it is. I'm filled with joy.
Happy. Happy joy. Joy. Happy. Happy joy.
Right.
Yeah.
So, everyone understand what it means to
be filled and what it doesn't mean.
Right.
Everyone got it